SPEAKER: As data science and
technology continue to advance,
we're seeing more and more
industries investigate how
their data can make an impact.
When it comes to
health care, data
is now at the very
heart of solutions
that help improve
patient outcomes
and allow scientists to
develop new therapies.
In today's video,
we're going to walk you
through an example of how
you might build a data
platform for advancing
clinical trials using Looker
and other Google Cloud Services.
And while we'll be
focusing on life sciences
research for today's
demonstration,
it's important to note
that these technologies can
be leveraged for a
variety of use cases
throughout the health
care industry and beyond.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In 2020, as many as
5.8 million Americans
were living with
Alzheimer's disease.
And this number is
projected to nearly triple
to 14 million people by 2060.
So today, we're
focusing on building
a data-powered application to
help physicians and researchers
analyze huge amounts
of information
to discover new
Alzheimer's treatments.
Let's dive in.
When it comes to working
with health care data,
privacy and data protection
are at the very forefront
of your technology
considerations.
Lucky for you, Google
Cloud is committed
to keeping your patient
data safe, with services
that meet fundamental
security and privacy
requirements for protected
health information.
Now that we have
housekeeping out of the way,
let's get back to the
fundamental problem.
When it comes to
analyzing new treatments,
there are loads of
different data sources
we need to consider--
MRIs and PET scans, patient
medical history data,
positive and
negative side effects
reported from drug
treatments, and lab data
collected over time.
And we're not just talking
about small volumes here.
Medical imaging alone generates
about 2 trillion images
per year, or nearly 4
and 1/2 exabytes of data.
OK, so we have lots of data
in all different structures,
how do we make
sense of all of this
and give practitioners
the insights they need?
Let's start by taking a
closer look at Looker.
Looker's architecture is unique
among business intelligence
platforms because it's
powered by Looker's modeling
layer, LookML,
which sits directly
on top of your data warehouse.
Looker is an
API-first application,
which provides data as a
service to other systems
by leveraging LookML,
Looker's modeling layer,
to deliver consistent data
across all applications.
In the application
we're building today,
BigQuery and Looker are the
primary analytical engines
for structured patient data.
But we'll also use Cloud
Storage to serve up
unstructured data, like images,
and Vision AI and TensorFlow
to add additional insights
into our BigQuery data.
Now the question is, how will
this architecture empower
health care professionals and
life sciences researchers?
Let's find out.
OK, so let's pretend
you're a health care
provider who has
patients participating
in a clinical trial.
You can navigate to the
application landing page
to see a high-level overview
of the trial, including
information like the
research question,
the trial status, when it
started, and the type of study.
Additionally, you can dig
into some of the details
for each treatment
group, like seeing
the severity level
and a breakdown of all
the participants.
Now, aside from simply
viewing high-level statistics,
you can interact with this data
by adjusting the timeline--
maybe to better understand if
the usage of each treatment
has changed
throughout the trial.
Now, the super cool
part of all this
is that we're using third-party
UI components for a custom
experience, but we're
still pulling data
from our unified data model,
ensuring data governance
and consistency.
OK, so you have a sense
of the overall trial,
now let's move over
to My Patients.
The first four tabs
over here allow
you to see detailed information
about patients, ranging
from the basic information,
like their sex, age, blood type,
and BMI, to more
complex information,
like medical events
and family history.
But that's not all.
Like we showed before,
interaction is key here.
So you can drill into things
like the hippocampal volume
to get more details on
what's going on here.
Now you can see a
modal pulling in data
through Looker's embedded
iframe, which we'll talk
through more in just a minute.
Back on my screen,
I can navigate
to the Predictive Insights tab.
And here, we'll be
able to see the results
of our artificial
intelligence solution,
where we can see things like a
description of the recommended
treatment and predicted positive
and negative side effects.
It's important to note that
Google Cloud toolset allows
us to feed in non-quantitative
data, like MRI images,
into a statistical model.
For example, using Vision AI,
we can identify and measure
the size of certain
neural structures.
These insights help
guide physicians
and ease the burden of searching
for microscopic structures
in the brain so they can
focus on treating and managing
their patient's health.
Now that you know
your treatment plan,
you can share details
with the patient
or send them directly to
the pharmacy to be filled.
So all this data in the
demo is stored in BigQuery,
but can be abstracted
further using Looker,
and fed into other microservices
across Google and beyond,
like the 3D brain studio over
here, which uses our technology
to take patient 2D
images and present it
in 3D for physicians.
Although custom and
hybrid solutions
create an amazing
experience for end users,
they can sometimes take
more effort to build.
Oftentimes, there's
a need to incorporate
standard embedded reports
because it enables
organizations to quickly
integrate dashboards
into applications.
Let's take a closer look.
Like we showed before
in our drill modal,
Looker dashboards can be fully
embedded through an iframe
to show the fastest
time to value
and allow developers to focus
on more custom feature sets.
If we go back to our
main application,
we can also navigate
to the trial data page.
Here, we'll be able to see
a more detailed overview
of all trial data,
with full access
to Looker's built-in
capabilities,
like scheduling and download
functionality, drilling,
and alerts.
Awesome.
So now you've seen how to
use Google Cloud to create
a tailored, custom
data experience.
By combining intelligent and
secure Google Cloud Services,
you can build
amazing applications
that leverage artificial
intelligence and data analytics
to design, build, and scale the
next generation of modern data
applications.
Ready to learn more?
Check out the links below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]